um all right I want to get to this
because I know this is going to take a
while uh but Candace Owens white Candace
Owens oh she's white Candace Owens
that's
right was on uh Tucker's show um
yesterday and I skipped to the part you
know the part that I oh did you find me
the Harvard time stamp Virgie yeah it's
19 minutes exactly by the way legally
speaking it's not a show oh sorry sorry
sorry Tucker's blog there you go Tucker
hey we're we're we're looking out for
you bud Tucker's personal blog
Fox his personal blog gets 40 million
views in a day hey what's up guys it's
your boy Tucker it's your boy Tucker 419
and we're coming at you yo smash that
like button hit the notification Bell
opening up Pokemon cards and hanging out
on Omegle oh my God you imagine
yes it could be right that's usually a
tell and speaking of so I was out of the
country yesterday um and didn't have
adequate internet access on the plane to
really follow this and I don't
understand the context exactly but um
the internet was dominated Yesterday by
video of Ben Shapiro who you work with
at the daily wire um I think it's fair
to say attacking you here's the video I
just want to get your reaction to
it yes the question is about Candace I
think her behavior during this disgrace
without a
[Applause]
I think she's been absolutely
disgraceful I think that I think that
her her F sophistication on these
particular issues has been ridiculous
it's not fux
sophistication look at the woman in the
corner like with her mouth
open that is kind of funny even even
some people there are like what is wrong
with you yeah they're like wrong how you
were wrong I haven't seen it um but to
call call somebody quote absolutely
disgraceful particularly a cooworker
seems like a pretty big step what and
and I really don't know the background
here what is that about you know there
isn't much of a background I saw the
video when everybody else saw it when I
woke up um no one he no one warned you
about it nobody warned me about it I I
it looks like yeah like the USS
Liberty or 911 yeah or Pearl Harbor how
far back we want to go you want JFK
honestly the the civil war Civil War be
the Civil War you know you know the I
forget the guy's name somebody can look
it up for me but it was uh the guy that
was in Jefferson Davis's ear the whole
time during the Confederate War was some
Jewish Banker no way I I got one for you
can you name can you name a war that's
that the US has been involved in since
World War II or actually just any war on
the [__] face of the planet since
World War II that hasn't started with a
false flag operation no no we know that
I mean that's pretty pretty standard
pretty standard
Behavior maybe he didn't know he was
being recorded it looks like it was some
sort of a private event I got no Clarity
on the issue that he was oh someone else
brought up October
7th there you go speaking on and they do
it to themselves I also I can't respond
to it beyond what he's saying because
it's just ad homant attacks I don't know
because it's not you know we disagree or
I you know I I don't think she's correct
or maybe she doesn't know what she's
talking about it's absolutely
disgraceful yeah exactly and so I can't
respond to it on a level of intellect
because there there's nothing that he
has expressed in that at least in that
short clip that he fundamentally
disagrees with in terms of what I said
but I will say that I'm not going to
respond with the same ad hopin and
attacks I don't think it helps further
discussion and it if that was me that
was caught on a video saying that about
colleagues that I work with I would be
embarrassed I would so I think that the
video speaks more to Ben's character
than it speaks to mine has he texted you
to apologize or explain or anything no
nothing I haven't heard a single Le word
it just was sort of something that he
said he's emotional Ben's being
emotional yeah f facts didn't care about
your feelings wow he's being like he's
being a woman you're being an emotional
woman Ben bennifer and you know what Ben
and I have many disagreements so I don't
think that that's particularly something
that's interesting um we disagreed on
the covid vaccine we disagree on Ukraine
and Russia he has taken virtually every
stance that has been the opposite of
mine on every issue uh over the last 5
years so I don't think that that's
particularly remarkable really I didn't
remember that yeah you did he did hold
on he did he did remember you think he's
just doing this on purpose really what
what did he say here what what oh wow
what let's remind people it's better you
say it's better if you just what
happened what happened he'd be great
interrogator actually really what' he
say yeah I I would imagine when he's
interrogating there's a lot of this
squinting going on like yeah what do he
say okay then it speaks to mine has he
texted you to apologize or explain or
anything no nothing I haven't heard a
single word it just was sort of
something that he said and you know what
Ben and I have many disagreement Andrew
claven sent me a one-word text message
and just said
[__] I don't know what that I don't know
what that meant I don't know what that
meant video speaks more to Ben's
character than it speaks to mine has he
texted you to apologize or explain or
anything no nothing I haven't heard a
single word it just was sort of
something that he said and you know what
Ben and I have many disagreements so I
don't think that that's particularly
something that's interesting um we
disagreed on the Cod vaccine we disagree
on Ukraine and Russia he has taken
virtually every stance that has been the
opposite of mine on every issue over the
last 5 years so I don't think that
that's particularly REM really I didn't
remember that yeah he was Pro the covid
vaccine I was anti- the vaccine you know
we were all idiots for not getting the
vaccine so that's totally fine I I am
totally that was the word used he said
don't be an idiot opinion I would hope
that amongst colleagues that it would
always be civil disagreement and I I
would never in a private event stand on
a table and talk badly about Ben the
stand on a table was a shock cuz he's
short that was a short joke that was a
way to say it where she go I wasn't
making s short you were on a table
though weren't you you were standing on
a table standing on a table yeah a
little it's a little weird so he was on
the left on those three biggest issues
of our time is
what o
uhoh
uhoh you know what I love hey you know
what Tucker it's pretty anti-semitic you
it is but you know what I love
that all these every all these people
that you know have always been above the
above the fry you know like we're real
like this is all journalism and whatever
like the Ben of Heroes and DA wire the
Candace Hogan not even on Tucker
Carlson it went from a bunch of idiots
screaming at each other like on
killstream for example to now they're
doing it now they're taking the gimmick
and they're doing it on like ma for
major networks from millions of people
these these used to be the news this
used to be the news the spirit of the
blood God has escaped into the regular
world broken containment God the the
blood God is broken containment holy
[__]
dude he has converted his opinions he's
accepted responsibility said you know I
was wrong about the vaccine uh he is
good for
him he's such a passive aggressive
[__] guy I've always said about
Tucker Tucker is Tucker is one of those
guys like that I know could make me lose
my cool I would jump over a [__]
table at Tucker if he was like being
that smug with me like he's so good at
it you know what I mean so I love when
it's directed at shitty people cuz this
is very fun to watch this is [__]
hilarious you know obviously profarma
his mom's a doctor and I say to people
I'm very aware of my perspectives on big
Pharma and I talk about it on my show
openly and I think that that's a
tremendous credit to the Daily wire that
they allow difference of opinions but I
would I as I said hope that somebody in
the jet says I'm a Centrist and can't
stand her name whatever her name is
Candace ens well you know her name and
and also yeah no one's made fun of can
someone's more than us what are you
talking we were Pioneers are you kidding
me go back we were making fun of
remember we had like Bunty King on in
like the [__] one of the first 20
episodes of the show we just ripped her
apart but back back when she was red
pill black but but that being said she's
right now she's right now and there's
nobody we you know who we hate more than
Candace Owens Ben Shapiro uhhuh it's
just look it's it's two people we hate
one we hat slightly less and they're
fighting to the death we're not saying
that either one of them's the good guy
we're saying let him
cook that's all just let him fight but
in this situation too she is everything
she's saying is
correct it would remain respectful and
that you wouldn't throw your colleagues
um under a bus so to speak I think
that's fair and just just for clarity
because I really don't know did is he
your boss does he I think there's a lot
of misunderstanding about uh Ben's
involvement Awesome Ben gave her the
thank you Jim anworth kill there's a
hierarchy of hate around here we have a
hierarchy of hate learn I know you're
new but learn the pyramid Ben's not even
at the top really but he's up there yeah
but you know there's probably people we
hate even more than Ben I mean a couple
I believe yeah I think so he is not
making aition of the daily wire and oh
this was okay this was shade sorry I
wanted to make sure we covered this is
shade listen to this is he your boss
does he I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding about uh Ben's
involvement he's not he's not the CEO of
the daily wire he's is not making the
day decisions of the daily wire and I do
want to make it very clear because
people are like how could you possibly
save daily wire after this this is a sh
I have a very good relationship with the
co- CEOs the daily wire I you know
especially right now the acting CEO is
uh Caleb Robinson he's a wonderful
person he's worked very hard to be where
he's at we have a lot in common that we
connect on and so people don't get to
see that which is unfortunate you know
Ben lives in Florida he's not a part of
the day-to-day movements daily wire you
know the rest of uh the hosts have their
shows situated in Nashville so so like
we're like a big family over there and
Ben's you know hiding out in Florida
everything she's saying is factually
true but she's doing it in the in a very
well she's a woman passive aggressive
way as taking shots at him each other
every day we talk there's great
camaraderie and there's actually more
agreement there's actually a lot of
people that are as I describ myself just
Pro America first and I think I've been
that way consistently throughout my
political career whether people agree
with it or not in different moments is
Up For Debate but there I I don't want
that video to become a reflection of how
the daily wire works and the daily wire
operates because I have had a very good
experience uh with the CEOs and you know
love Michael noes love Matt Walsh Andrew
C we all get look someone has
to really great well certainly speak
yeah okay if you love them eat their
chocolate on camera yeah tell us how
good it is don't cringe yes you swell
the daily wire then so it's not I mean a
clip like that by the way inter Ken is
out where did just you know leave Brett
Cooper out throw a little shade there to
does throw her a little later oh does
she or something that's not doesn't
sound like that's what it means at all
yeah no it's a you know it's it's a
small group of people we see each other
every day Brett Cooper is another one
who just joined about two years ago
she's great she's up and coming see what
she's doing is it it's an isolation
tactic oh yeah no she is we all know
what she's doing you all see what she's
doing it's an isolation tactic where you
surround you tell Ben you're not even
here I I'm we have lunch and stuff every
day uh Brett you know the you're one you
little joke around with cuz she looks
like yeah but she's in Nashville and
like we've been talking and think
Candace is buying pizzas every once in a
while oh no no no no not pizza she walks
in with donuts every day and goes don't
worry they're Co oh wait Ben's not here
it doesn't matter and she puts him down
they all have a good laugh and they'll
have a
laugh and they all
laugh because the reason that they
couldn't the reason the reason that they
couldn't order schwarma wasn't there
anymore and hey I know we ran out of K
Cups I've just brought some from home
yeah you're
welcome guys we could cook bacon again
if we want we're allow man Candace is
really going to win this it's gonna be
really fun to watch she's so much better
at it than him hey did you notice ever
since Ben shapir left there wasn't a
kosher microwave anymore that's pretty
cool huh wasn't that
cool I had a ham and cheese sandwich
yesterday and nobody judged me for it
nope on that's why I think this video is
even more unfortunate you know what I
did Saturday shout out some emails cuz
I'm not restricted like
that that's hilarious because people see
him I'm not hamstrung on a Saturday I
can get work done and rightfully so of
the daily wire and it allows people to
you know speak energy into the daily
wire that isn't necessarily there
because he's not there on DayDay okay
that's very interesting so if we can
take three steps back and give us the
context for this debate how are you on
different sides of it well he's Trish so
um he feels entitled to all of our
foreign aid and he feels that we should
just blindly support a country that's
been a liability to us for 20 years and
I I I disagree and I'm I'm a black I'm a
black woman so I'm not going to shut up
exactly this this is a fight we're
having here and I'm a black woman so I'm
not going to shut up so I heard you
endorsing Hamas like you're not no well
I have not endorsed Hamas in any way and
yet people have interpreted things that
I I am endorsing Hamas right now with
some pine nuts like some chili delicious
no no that's hummus you're thinking of
hummus the the I got to write some
emails I made I made a huge I made a
huge mistake a pretty big mistake I got
us the wrong sponsorship I apologize how
much are they paying more than Bor gold
was let out I love him look let's hear
him out look I'll take the jew2 you guys
just haven't offered any yet yeah Birch
cold yeah you guys stopped doing running
hands with us and we would have dialed
it back or actually rather things that I
don't say it's becoming very much
remniscent to me and why I have used my
platform to say this of black lives
matter matter where if you don't say
anything they say your silence is
violence if you say something and it's
evenhanded and it's nuanced which is to
say you know during the times of black
lives matter you might say I don't
support and she's right she's saying
what we were saying yesterday which is
like you all are sounding exactly like
[__] leftist lunatics you're all
sounding the same way you're doing the
same thing you're telling people shut up
pick a pi not picking a side doesn't
matter did you did you see the uh it was
a gift of a DJ khed and he was dancing
and it's like take Cal moving away from
actually taking a stance on this so he
could still sell records it was very
funny it was very funny that's hilarious
has he been like not just quiet well
yeah quiet he's smart he's smart to be
quiet you know make money Instagram and
you maybe were busy that day maybe you
were in another country you know maybe
you just didn't log on to Instagram you
were accused of being a racist I'm
seeing a lot of that behavior right now
when it comes to the Israeli Palestinian
conflict a conflict that I have seen
every single person including myself
condemn what happened on October 7th I
have because who wouldn't condemn
terrorism it's OB who would not condemn
innocent oh us when it's happening in
Yemen sorry I I thought yeah we don't we
don't yeah or Li there's a lot of places
we don't condemn it
Palestine not really doing a lot of
condemning of that are we lot of dead
babies lots of dead kids dying but if
you then say that it is also sad when
innocent Palestinian child dies suddenly
this is pramas or you need to say even
when you're talking about how sad it is
that a child dies you need to button
that statement by saying but that child
was a human shield that's not going to
be my response um first off as a mother
that's not going to be my response as
somebody who was about to do to give
birth you're not a mother yet it didn't
make it yet calm down [__] it'll get
there children involved on both sides of
the conflict I pointed to the the people
that are mocking dead Israeli children
and said that they are horrific I am
even keil on this matter and yet people
think that you need to be extreme so
people that have become more radical and
extreme are perceiving a moderate stance
as not enough and I was about to say you
don't people can disagree with you or
agree with you or whatever but you
certainly don't seem radical on this
topic she's not skateboarding that's how
I know she's not yeah dude and let me
you see at the other time stamp 19
exactly you said right okay so yeah
that's right where it starts and Mer was
bringing this one brought this up before
the show and I did see this and I didn't
grab it but here we go I'll move it up
little bit give me a second man Twitter
is so good their video is so good I
should have just pulled it up on YouTube
their streaming is so good I have to
like refresh
now sorry guys in 16 don't worry this is
going to replace
YouTube college campuses hasn't changed
did you not remember what they were
saying what professors were saying the
however then in New York City right now
that is explicit anti-white racism that
is happening and I covered it on my show
extensively nobody cared there there was
no bus calling these kids anything wrong
and so trying to explain that of why
people maybe are not reacting um with
the amount of vigor that you would like
to see is now being interpreted as
anti-Semitism so everyone's being called
an it's a little bit like watching the
city of San Francisco in the week before
xan ping shows up become totally clean
sparkling clean there are no junkies or
rapists on the street
and you feel like asking the authorities
well wait you had the power to do this
but you didn't you had the power to stop
racism at Harvard but you didn't why are
you not a criminal actually for allowing
that I don't like have you asked anybody
this like direct have you asked a donor
this I've been trying to get one on the
show I say I support what you're doing
it's great don't pay for what you don't
like but you did like the the white
genocide stuff you're kind of okay with
that even asked have you did you use
your platform to speak out against it
because I've been speaking out against
this for years now you're demanding that
I use my platform to to focus on a
conflict that's overseas and the answer
I tend to get is no uh I I didn't talk
about what was happening I didn't
realize it it was happening so it
actually is quite a selfish Viewpoint
which we all have we're all guilty of I
get it we we write ourselves into the
storyline how is this going to impact me
and that is I think is why it feels
existential for other people and not
existential people that have been
dealing with this for the last decade I
know but it's a pretty simple principle
that I mean existed at 54 I can tell you
in this country for a long time
certainly from say the civil right act
until I don't know 15 years ago you're
not allowed to attack people in the base
of the race in public you are
now you are now and that's where we are
now well it's it's nice to see people
having these conversations it's nice to
see [__] people yeah talk saying
stuff that when we were saying it years
ago we were getting [__] in trouble
whoa yeah I
know